[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 y
más romeros a las se ríe porque yo
quiero entender mi cerebro mar algo tan
complicado para todos un órgano
espectacular con muchos estímulos muchas
terminaciones nerviosas mejor dicho mar
y porque vamos a hablar de cerebro
porque hoy se celebra el día mundial de
nuestro cerebro el motor después sé todo
lo que somos prácticamente también
digamos a nivel no sé si espiritual de
inteligencia lo que sea vamos con una
historia un dato curioso y un bulo mar
buenos días raúl efectivamente creo que
si tú quieres comprender el cerebro
todos queremos comprender el nuestro
pero es que ni los científicos haciendo
las investigaciones más avanzadas
todavía en logrado entender el total de
su funcionamiento pero como decíamos
vamos a empezar con este dato histórico
para eso vamos a viajar al continente
africano a egipto más de tres mil años
atrás miles 600 antes de cristo en ese
momento fue cuando cuando se escribió el
primer documento que tenemos registrado
que habla del cerebro que describe por
primera vez este órgano es un papiro se
llama el papiro de edwin schmidt porque
este es el investigador
bueno que más bien lo compro para ser
justos con la historia en
1862 aunque se cree que podría ser un
texto que viniera de mucho antes que
copiará algo de milenios incluso atrás
es especialmente interesante porque como
decía raúl siempre ha habido una especie
de batalla en la historia médica por
comprender si es el corazón o el cerebro
el director de orquesta de nuestro
cuerpo ahora se sabe que mucho más de
eso recae sobre el cerebro pero antes de
hecho los mismos egipto egipcios creía
que era el corazón el que hacía todo
esto sin embargo en este papel es la
primera vez que se describe que el
cerebro podría tener algo que ver con la
función motora porque está haciendo un
diagnóstico de un hombre que recibió una
herida en la cabeza y que está herida en
la cabeza hacía que se le pudiera ver
hasta el mismo órgano del cerebro así
empieza con una herida abierta en la
cabeza que penetra hasta el hueso
describe que este cerebro tiene una
forma de cobre fundido y también
describe que tiene pulso es decir que
sienten como vibra el cerebro además
pues como decíamos describe que este
hombre tiene dificultades para andar y
por eso decimos que esa primera
asociación al menos que se sepa se hizo
en la historia de la medicina entre el
cerebro y las funciones tan vitales como
caminar mar bueno ahora ya sabemos mucho
más de nuestro cerebro no que vamos a
ver ahora cómo continuamos este repaso
por este órgano hablaba del corazón mar
yo también digo que pues obviamente la
manera romántica pues uno dice el
corazón pero todo lo que sentimos está
acá todos los estímulos que uno manda
cuando uno se con uno siente amor cuando
uno siente tristeza miedo pues todo
viene de aquí y posiblemente la gran
mayoría de todos estos sentimientos son
hormonas que reciben los
neurotransmisores y que provocan pues
todas esas reacciones en nuestro cerebro
hoy en día como decía sabemos mucho más
aunque bueno todavía falta mucho por
saber y empezamos por algunos datos
curiosos por ejemplo sabemos que tiene
al menos 86 mil millones de neuronas
aunque se cree que podría ser incluso
más podrían ser algunos dicen que
100.000 millones sabemos que la
información viaja tan deprisa mucho más
deprisa por ejemplo que un coche en su
velocidad habitual de carretera a 240
kilómetros por hora eso significa que
pasa una fracción de segundo entre que
por ejemplo sientes una en el pie hasta
que tu cerebro
recibe esa información y también sabemos
que supone el 2% de nuestra masa
corporal pero requiere hasta el 20 por
ciento una quinta parte de todas
nuestras necesidades de oxígeno y de
calorías entonces hablando de calorías
precisamente te quería preguntar tú eres
de esos que se pone de mal humor cuando
tiene hambre yo a no sabes que
últimamente me ha pasado pero hay laura
nuestra productora nos dice que ya si
ellas y bueno pues laura y yo somos dos
al menos aquí algún neurotransmisor te
está fallando porque ese es el trato
curioso que queremos explicar hoy no ese
fenómeno de que la gente se pone como
irritado cuando no ha comido porque
bueno el cerebro detecta que es momento
de comer porque por varias cosas una de
ellas por ejemplo el nivel del estómago
si está lleno o está vacío pero también
por el nivel de azúcar en sangre el
cerebro necesita una cantidad gigante de
glucosa para funcionar mucho más en
cualquier caso que otros órganos de
nuestro cuerpo y para contrarrestar esta
falta de glucosa cuando no hemos comido
bien el cerebro anda unas órdenes de
producir una serie de hormonas que
ayudan a mantener precisamente el nivel
de glucosa hormonas son pues una es la
adrenalina muy conocida otras del
cortisol las dos son hormonas que
generan se generan cuando por ejemplo
estamos estresados o en situaciones como
de lucha de supervivencia incluso
entonces es una de las explicaciones que
manejan todavía de hecho una hipótesis
por este fenómeno de que algunas
personas se pongan irritables cuando
tienen hambre sin embargo como decíamos
tampoco se tiene la completa certeza de
esto porque nos falta muchísimo para
comprender y desvelar del todo a este
órgano hablabas algo también de la
velocidad del cerebro de la velocidad en
la que pensamos más de 240 kilómetros
por hora y yo creo que también yo a mí
me pasa yo pienso mucho pienso demasiado
rápido a veces cuando quiero hablar pues
no como que me trago es que también eso
es por lo rápido que piensen en su
cerebro que pues no sabré contestarte
con el 100% de certeza pero en cualquier
caso claro en el cerebro coordina muchas
funciones a la vez es decir pensar y
hablar son cosas que a veces llevamos
conjuntamente pero no siempre entonces
coordinar todas esas funciones es normal
y más por ejemplo si no has desayunado
unos en algunos momentos y para terminar
porque aquí yo me puedo quedar hablando
toda una vida contigo marc sobre nuestro
cerebro una creencia falsa que tengamos
sobre nuestro cerebro bueno es el mito
este de que no lo usamos por completo
obviamente que incluso llega a decir que
son los 10 por ciento de nuestro cerebro
está funcionando y que estamos
desaprovechando nuestra capacidad claro
nos gusta mucho incluso inspirado
películas o libros no esa idea de que
podemos ser como súper humanos tener
mucha inteligencia si fuéramos capaces
de desbloquear todo el potencial de
nuestro cerebro pero este al menos esta
cifra del 10 por ciento sabemos con
certeza que eso sí es mentira porque por
ejemplo pues para realizar una función
tan básica como es caminar ya usamos más
del 10 por ciento al menos de regiones
del cerebro están implicadas funciones
motoras pero también el equilibrio
también a la visión la percepción del
espacio a la decisión y eso ya ni
siquiera pues las personas que van
caminando y van pensando imagínate allí
todas las áreas del cerebro que están
activadas muchísimo más que el 10%
tampoco es cierto si lo pensamos en el
10 por ciento de las neuronas decíamos
que tenemos miles de millones de
neuronas tendría muy poco sentido
ni siquiera que un órgano del cual solo
usamos el 10 nos requiera el 20 por
ciento de las calorías o del oxígeno que
tomamos que sí que es cierto que puede
inspirar un poco eso bueno pues que el
cerebro tiene una capacidad de
reorganizarse
increíble que tampoco comprendemos del
todo todavía a día de hoy pero que hay
personas pues que es verdad que les da
se les ha dañado parte del cerebro que
por algún motivo no les funciona y que
el cerebro es capaz de igualmente de
cumplir todas las funciones vitales y de
funcionar con normalidad porque es un
órgano extremadamente plástico y aquí
pues nosotros más lo utilizamos
muchísimo para las personas a lo mejor
que no saben por ejemplo nosotros
estamos leyendo aquí la noticia nos
están hablando por acá estamos pendiente
de la hora estamos pendiente de lo que
sigue pues hay uno va tan bien como
ejercitando el cerebro lo importante es
usar releerlo mantenernos siempre como
una actividad nerd lo activo y no sólo
eso sino también es muy importante decir
que la sociabilidad del no estar solo es
el excitar el cerebro también en el
ámbito social hablar con gente conocer
eso también se ha demostrado que es una
de estas cosas que ejercita digamos el
cerebro y que de hecho puede prevenir a
largo plazo algunas enfermedades más de
tenemos que es feliz porque si no aquí
ya la ofrece
tenemos que ya entonces y con hambre
peor nos tiene que ya tenemos que tener
tiempo para la sección de deportes de
mar esa ya está lista para hablar
muchísimas gracias mar como siempre por
toda la información feliz fin de semana
nos vemos el lunes con más información
acerca de nuestra salud